la grande différence à partir de lundi
de la voici port du masque obligatoire
dans les transports en commun alors sur
le réseau dijonnais pas de grands
changements
toujours interdiction de montée par
l'avant dans les bus le chauffeur est
toujours isolée d'une plaque de
plexiglas des voyageurs sera bien sûr
respecter la distance sociale d'un mètre
minimum des stickers vont être apposés
sur certains sièges pour respecter cette
distance depuis le début du confinement
tous les tramways et les bus du réseau
sont nettoyés quotidiennement
[Musique]
pour le moment pas de système de
marquage prévu sur les quais des
tramways alors dans les tramways même
dispositif que dans les bus il faut
respecter la distanciation d'un mètre
est toujours interdiction de montée par
l'avant du véhicule
[Musique]
on l'a vu les consignes de sécurité sont
très strictes mais au-delà de ça tout le
monde de divia sera sur le pont on le
voit avec thomas fontaine directeur de
dijon qui hollis mobilité dites moi
monsieur fontaine alors comment ça va se
passer à partir de lundi bah écoutez à
partir de lundi prochain on remet en
place une offre à 70% d'une offre normal
cette période là donc on va tous être
mobilisés au niveau de divia pour être
présent sur le terrain et ré accueillir
l'ensemble des personnes sur des
cadences de 7 minutes sur le tram et sur
des cadences en moyenne sur les lignes
importantes de bus de 10 12 minutes
les entrées des principales gares de la
région seront filtrés la sncf a mis
également en place une signalétique pour
réguler orienter le flux des voyageurs
des voyageurs qui pourront se tenir
informé de l'affluence dans les trains
chose importante à signaler la présence
de ces bornes de gel hydroalcoolique
[Musique]
alors comme pour les tramways et les bus
et trains sont désinfectés tous les
jours et comme dans les autres moyens de
transport
les sièges sont en cours d'année un sur
deux avec un petit sticker comme vous le
voyez ici qui mentionne que ce siège est
condamné alors pour savoir ce qu'il va
advenir lundi dans nos trains ne sommes
en présence de monsieur eric ciotti le
directeur régional de la sncf bfc alors
dites moi comment
d'abord pour tous nos voyageurs le port
du masque obligatoire
et puis ce qui est important de savoir
c'est qu'à partir du lundi 11 mai
l'ensemble des lignes sncf ter vont
rouvrir bourgogne franche comté
il y aura des trains sur toutes les
lignes ça fera un total de 230 train
c'est à dire un peu plus d'un tiers de
l'offre habituelle
du côté des transports scolaires pas de
port de masque obligatoire pour les
enfants c'est ce qu'a décidé le
gouvernement
les transports devraient reprendre le 14
mai date de rentrée dans les écoles
primaires
[Musique]